el siguiente fin de semana iré con mis
abuelos la mochila que tengo dice que el
peso máximo que soporta es de 5
kilogramos así que debo cuidar cuántas
cosas llevo para no superar esa cantidad
mi mamá quiere mandarles varias cosas
1.7 kilogramos de café un quinto de
kilogramo de nueces dos kilos y un
cuarto de granola y 1.2 kilos de
almendras para saber si mi mamá puede
mandar más cosas y si la mochila
soportará el peso
tenemos que sumar todas las cantidades
pero no si están con decimales y otras
con fracción mantengamos la calma lo
primero que hay que hacer es organizar
nuestros datos en una tabla al irla
llenando veremos que no es difícil
convertir de decimal la fracción o al
revés entonces son 1.7 kilogramos de
café así que lo colocamos en la columna
de decimal de nuez es un quinto de
kilogramo y nos pasamos a la columna de
fracción
para la granola nos quedamos en la
columna de fracción porque son 2 kilos y
un cuarto
y en la columna de decimal la almendra
que son 1.2 kilos
para completar la tabla hay que
convertir las cantidades para facilitar
esto hagamos unas anotaciones con
información útil es bueno saber que un
kilogramo equivale a un entero ya sea en
fracción o decimal
entonces medio kilo será la mitad de ese
entero es decir en fracciones un medio y
en decimal equivale a 0.5 kilogramos si
lo volvemos a dividir a la mitad
tendremos que un cuarto equivale a 0.25
otra anotación útil es que para obtener
un décimo de kilo hay que dividir entre
10 entonces en fracción se escribe como
un décimo y en expresión decimal un
décimo se escribe 0.1 con estas
anotaciones será muy fácil convertir de
una columna a otra
de café tenemos 1.7 kilogramos en
fracción equivale a un entero y el punto
7 son 7 décimos es decir siete veces 0.1
por lo tanto de café es un entero con
siete décimos
hagamos lo mismo con la almendra tenemos
un entero con dos décimos
pero dos décimos tiene fracción
equivalente y se simplifica como un
quinto así que queda como un entero y un
quinto vamos con la nuez para convertir
de fracción a decimal se hace la
división del numerador entre el
denominador en este caso dividimos 1
entre 5 para saber la equivalencia de un
quinto y el resultado de la división es
0.2 para los dos kilos de un cuarto
tomamos dos kilos como dos enteros en
nuestras anotaciones está la
equivalencia de un cuarto y es 0.25
así que sumamos estos datos y obtenemos
2.25
ahora ya podemos sumar cualquier columna
en el caso de las fracciones hay
denominadores diferentes y sería más
tardado porque necesitamos buscar un
común denominador si sumamos los
decimales será más fácil 1.7 más 0.2 más
2.25 mas 1.2 es igual a las 5.35
superamos la capacidad de la mochila
habrá que decirle a mi mamá que quite
0.35 kilos lo que quiere mandar porque
sólo podemos llevar 5 kilos esto lo
pudimos haber estimado con las
fracciones si te das cuenta de cuatro
enteros uno más dos más uno de los siete
décimos del café sólo se necesitan tres
décimos más para completar un kilo y así
llegar a los cinco y todavía tenemos un
quinto un cuarto y otro quinto
seguro nos pasábamos porque los cuartos
y los quintos son más grandes que los
décimos
no hicimos ninguna operación compleja y
pudimos llenar nuestra tabla sigue
practicando para calcular la suma de
diversas cantidades sin importar si
están como decimal o como fracción